HAVE THE LOCATION MUCH MORE
NARROW DOWN.
>> Bret: WE WILL FOLLOW IT,
RICK, THANK YOU.
AS MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW, THERE WERE INTENSE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT MONEY TO PAY FOR
HER CAN, PAST, PRESENT AND
FUTURE.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS THAT PART OF
THE STORY TONIGHT.
>> IS HURRICANE DORIAN TURNS OFF
THE PUERTO RICAN COAST, A
POLITICAL TEMPEST ERUPTED
BETWEEN SAN JUAN'S MAYOR AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AFTER THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
CONGRESS APPROVED $92 BILLION
FOR PUERTO RICO LESTER, HE FIRED
BACK, CONGRESS HAS APPROVED
40,000,000,014,000,000,000 HAD
BEEN DISPERSED, TO WHICH
PRESIDENT TRUMP REPLIED
PUERTO RICO IS ONE OF THE MOST
CORRUPT PLACES ON EARTH ADDING
BY THE WAY, I'M THE BEST THING
THAT'S EVER HAPPENED TO
PUERTO RICO.
IN TRUTH, CONGRESS APPROVED
$42.7 BILLION FOR PUERTO RICO.
OF THAT COME ABOUT 21 BILLION
HAS BEEN OBLIGATED AND LESS THAN
14 BILLION SPENT.
TO GET TO 92 BILLION, THE
PRESIDENT IS INCLUDING AN OMB
ESTIMATE THAT AN ADDITIONAL
50 BILLION WOULD BE NEEDED OVER
THE LIFE OF THE RECOVERY, BUT IT
IS NOT MONEY APPROVED BY
CONGRESS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO FOUND
HIMSELF UNDER ATTACK OVER PLANS
TO REPROGRAM MONEY FROM FEMA'S
DISASTER RELIEF FUND TO ADDRESS
THE BORDER CRISIS.
AS PART OF A $271 MILLION
SHUFFLE, DHS WOULD USE
155 MILLION OF FEMA MONEY TO PAY
FOR TEMPORARY IMMIGRATION
FACILITIES ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
ANOTHER $116 MILLION WILL BE
TAKEN FROM OTHER AGENCIES TO PAY
FOR MORE SINGLE ADULT DETENTION
BEDS.
DEMOCRATS WORK QUICK TO CONDEMN
THE MOVE.
IN A STATEMENT, HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI SAYING "TO
PICK THE POCKETS OF DISASTER
RELIEF FUND IN ORDER TO FUND AN
APPALLING, INHUMANE FAMILY
INCARCERATION PLAN A STAGGERING
INTRODUCE ON THE EVE OF
HURRICANE SEASON IS STUNNINGLY
RECKLESS."
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS PUSHED
BACK JUST AS HARD.
>> THAT'S HYSTERIA AND THE
REALITY IS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT ADMINISTRATIONS DO
CONSTANTLY, TO REAP PROGRAM.
>> IN FACT, PRESIDENT OBAMA TO
THE SAME THING IN AUGUST OF
2014, SHIFTING EVEN MORE MONEY
FOR THE BORDER CRISIS.
A TOTAL OF $405 BILLION WERE
PROGRAMMED, 2,676,000,000 CAME
FROM FEMA'S DISASTER RELIEF
FUND.
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T ARGUE WITH
THAT, BUT THEY SURE ARE
COMPLAINING NOW.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING
"TAKING THESE CRITICAL FUNDS
FROM DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS THREATENS LIVES
AND WEAKENS THE GOVERNMENT'S
ABILITY TO HELP AMERICANS IN THE
WAKE OF NATURAL DISASTERS."
FEMA OFFICIALS SAY THAT IS NOT
NOT THE CASE.
THE MONEY COMES FROM AN ACCOUNT
DEDICATED TO PREPOSITIONING
SUPPLIES AHEAD OF THE HURRICANE
AND THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF MONEY
IN THAT ACCOUNT TO LAST UNTIL
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR.
ANOTHER ACCOUNT THAT ACTUALLY
DEALS WITH RECOVERY IS FLUSH
WITH CASH AND HAS A BALANCE OF
$27 BILLION.